[موسيقى]
وضع قانون المنظمات الفاسده والممارسه
للبتزاز المعروف اختصارا بقانون ريكو عام
1970 لمكافحه الجرائم المنظمه والعصابات
استخدم لاحقا لا سيما في 89
غير المشروع او حتى من يحاول ارتكابها
لتحقيق مصلحه منظمه اجراميه ويشمل نحو 40
جريمه تراوح بين الجنح البسيطه والجنايات
الخطيره في حين تتفاوت عقوبه الادانه تحت
ظل القانون بين خمس سنوات وعشرين سنه وقد
جرى تعديل القانون في ولايه جورجيا ليشمل
المشاركين في الجرائم تخدم هدفا واحدا
وليس بالضروره منظمه اجراميه لكن كيف يمكن
ان يؤثر قانون ريكو في المحكمه ترامب يتيح
قانون ريكو ادانت ترامب دون الحاجه الى
اثبات انه اعطى الاوامر لقلب نتيجه
الانتخابات اذ يكفي فقط انه تامر مع
المتهمين الاخرين لتحقيق ذلك بحسب الخبراء
فان قانون ريكو يحفز المتهمين الذين لم
يؤدوا دورا كبيرا في محاوله قلب نتيجه
الانتخابات والمهددين بفتره سجن طويله على
عقد صفقه على ادعاء لتخفيض عقوبتهم مقابل
معلومات تدين ترامب ومع وجود 18 متهما ذوي
مسؤوليات متفاوته فان اللجوء اي منهم لهذه
الخطوه يبقى امرا واردا في حال ادانه
ترامب فقد يحكم عليه بالسجن لمده طويله لا
تقل عن خمس سنوات ما يعني انهاء مسيرته
السياسيه وطموحه بالعوده الى البيت الابيض
[موسيقى]